this is Startalk Michael Foley coming to
us from Google+ wants to know this is
GMO too broad a category for any single
statement organisms grown from
individually edited sequences of DNA be
treated the same as that grown meat as
golden rice as grain hybrid grains as
heirloom tomatoes also we've at grow
mammoth now I don't know what the hell
that there was those guys who want to
take mammoth jeans and oh yeah want to
make a bully man like Jurassic Park cuz
there's an Indian elephant right now
that actually is only one small bit away
from Jack who are you you're all over
this yeah yeah anyway I don't know how I
remember all this crap uh so this is
what he wants to know is it too proud of
a category for any single statement I
mean is it all the same or is there a
difference or you know he's saying well
I've said many times you got to go case
by case but that's what we do that's
what the the people who are growing
genetically modified crops especially
that's their deal okay they absolutely
do go case by case but it comes to use
of words it's a really hard thing to
control words are organic that is to say
they their bottom up somebody coins a
term that people like right it sticks
right is this a tomato or an heirloom
tomato right uh is it yellow or red I
mean so these words are hard to control
that when you start trying to tell
people no this is not genetically
modified this is intraspecies you're
just going to get into a fistfight about
semantics right so really it's not about
semantics it's about going case-by-case
and seeing what works how it does it but
in the big picture in the broad stroke
okay I claim genetically modified crops
are a good thing that's that they're
cooked there to the benefit of humankind
so that's your baseline right there
right there and what happened was when
the genetically modified cotton
especially was introduced and then the
corn and soybeans that was in the middle
of 1990s
was kind of the same afternoon that the
bovine spongiform encephalitis the BSE
the mad cow disease okay emerged
especially in Britain yes and the two
things got conflated BSE got mixed with
GMO and people thought they were all the
same they thought it was industrial
farming the man controlling things and
making everybody sick but they really
those two really are separate separate
issues gotcha spongiform encephalitis
mad cow disease where your brains turns
to a sponge right is separate from corn
that the corn borer insect can't eat
gotcha God you can about you can so
we're not susceptible to that protein
passes right through us not to give you
too much information okay good no I now
I realize what happened to me last night
okay you don't even know sorry we can't
even notice yeah it was right on through
right on through huh got you all right
well that makes sense okay so there you
have it Michael there's your answer
manage but what about the mammoth how do
you feel about the mammoth do you want
to make one I absolutely do I think be
the cool i think i'd be the greatest
thing in the world to actually see a
woolly mammoth walking around man I mean
I'm it would be the only animal i would
actually advocate being in a zoo uh
because i don't believe in zoos but but
with that said where else would that
technology lead like if you could
successfully do that could you bring
back the Great Auk could you bring back
other useful species that would the
frogs the frogs that are being so
stressed by that fungus could we bring
all those animals back in a way that we
would have more diversity in the
ecosystem based on this trial with the
mammoth these are great question i have
no problem with anything that you just
said as long as we're not bringing back
predators are you doing something that
would lengthen you were all the angles
of heaven right you know that Chuck it's
really hard to get eaten by a lion I
mean you have two especially just
everybody honesty we're in New York City
we're not going to get attacked by a
lion you know I wrestled on that listen
there was a woman who made all the
papers just last week bill and
I hate to actually date the show but
there was a woman who I'll say recently
was killed by a lion taking a for taking
a picture of the lion she was trying to
photograph the line basically it's a
Sean Penn lion and it killed her so it
cuz she left a window open even though
everybody said close the window I hereby
sign this thing I shall keep my windows
closed listen the lion alright and on an
opportunity in that case to that I shall
say nevermind well but so that's one
woman out of seven point almost 3
billion people right that's just not a
very common way to get the same with
shark biting it happens but you're not
that much alright so my fears are
unfounded well not i mean just keep them
in perspective you struck by lightning
zwey more likely this is Startalk